so I think the definition of immersion
should be much broader than just going
to a country and assuming you can start
speaking to people you can't there's so
many things so many ways you can immerse
yourself in the language before going so
that when you do go there you can get
greater Advantage from the potential
immersion opportunities that are there I
am determined to continue with my
reading and passive immersion activities
on link where I have a number of books
on uh polish history and it's good to do
something like history using different
resources just like with language you
want to cover the same ground using
different resources and I think
that already now I think my capability
to speak would be better than it was
when I arrived in Krakow